[Applause]
now
hey now you know hey now you know hey
now
i know i was going to say you know
hey now i was going to say hey now i'd
like to start
off with you know hey now
hey now robin what i was going to say
hey now
hey now hey now hey now
i'm stuck in the hay now vortex all
right
some quarantine sex tips wouldn't really
hit the spot right now ronnie what's
your sex tip for jimmy
oh he's asleep i don't even think he can
hear us rodney unmute yourself
ronnie's never had a computer before
what is this
all right where's escape where's command
quit
[Laughter]
who is that gary hey guy what's up
what's gary doing i don't know it was
weird i'm sorry howard i just
i just don't want to be involved in
anything i thought it was a mistake no
problem i'll recover
quickly i'm not distracted at all by
gary popping in and out of the
school hey man how you feeling i'm doing
really well
thanks man um you know i was talking to
the guys about benji
and you notice now you can't get a
camera angle right this goes on
every meeting that he's involved in let
me see you look normal on zoom
i can't even see you why do you not know
how to do it what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
it's fine wait what's wrong with it
right now wait what's wrong
oh look richards is doing something what
are you doing richard
how does that sound we can't hear
anything
yeah it cuts out yeah for some reason
it's killing the
speaker telling my show whatever he's
doing
[Music]
he's drumming his brains out the guy who
invented zoom a lot of people don't know
this hated drummers
whenever someone hits a drum it never
works on zoom
why are you not watching my dancing but
you can't hear me
put your headphones in well i'll do the
show without robin today
earth to robin
she's in one of those witches trances
you know we've been on the air for like
three minutes
jd who is it the one you're hot for
let's not say that again sorry why
wouldn't you pay attention to me we're
on the air
he's got that video game going you could
see all the red and everything flashing
what was going on with your mic yeah
really yeah
[Music]
the part i like is that you can see into
people's homes now if i told you where i
was right now you died don't come don't
don't don't i'm gonna send you a picture
wait actually you know what you do you
want to tell them where we
my arms are on the toilet tank and the
toilet is up against this window
in my background yo come here bert
yes sir this is one of my facilitators
what's up howard
it sounds to me like you're not
observing the rules of the coronavirus
you want to see my barber
your mic but tracy we're
and she got a temperature gun you love
football
what do you got oh there's your patriots
what is that
belichick's hoodie wow he gave you that
yeah first of all do you want me to give
you some of my old clothes you can hang
on a wall
oh wait you want to see the baby oh yeah
you see that baby
produced let's see what i did wow oh my
goodness he's so cute
he is cute robin
here he comes here comes oh now you're
talking about one
good looking boy have you been rolling
in that's a good good boy yeah
oh he gave you a test i'm digging your
basement
are those all video games yeah they're
all uh they're all like
those arcade video games that i put in
there to look cool
you love video games i love video games
it's it's mainly for my little cousins
that come and play and they just
rip the knobs off and i have to
reassemble them did jim carrey buy
charlie chaplin's cane well that i can
show you right now you want to see
yeah i want to see it this is actually
the truth
wow it's thinner than i thought it would
be i thought it came would be much
thicker
and insignificant and he made the world
with this thing
you have a flat ronnie yeah this is the
one i took
on tour i had it delivered yesterday
left it outside overnight for covid to
get covered off of ronnie
all those guitars on your wall are those
your personal guitars or those guitars
people gave you
those three right there those are what
we call them rickenbackers
now did you like the band absolutely so
that bass actually belonged to rick
danko
if you see the last waltz and he's
playing the weight
with the staple singers and that's
actually that one there this is
the first guitar of my dad's that he
gave me
he gave me a card with it and he was
really proud of the joke it's a playboy
card
but when he said it it was like play boy
you know that's what he wrote he was
really proud of like the 3d effect he
did
where is brad now his office is on the
other end of the house
and so uh we have this system here
intercom system no
oh my god wait a second
you you ring you ring that bell and and
brad comes running there he is
jd was quite concerned that his body
will die but
our brains might survive yeah how long
are you just laying there and possibly
knowing you're just laying there
quarantine
thoughts with jd meyer
i i think yeah i thought about a lot
lately is your brain
still being alive while you're dead like
you're just sort of
what can you still feel while you're
dead and you can't emote or whatever you
know
something in you but you just can't
emote it or whatever you just can't you
know
because you don't fully know because
you're dead
you can't really research that because
you would have to be dead
to fully know a remnants of uh
brain energy and matter or whatever
is still coursing through you know still
something i've thought like i could be
laying in a casket
and not being able to move or anything
and know that i'm laying in the casket
and just nothing is happening nothing
just happened
nothing has happened
i don't think anything's happening right
now
richard has a bathroom that is his and
his wife has
her own bathroom they've divided up the
house we're gonna take a tour right now
so here we go it's like a haunted house
oh okay i love how that sounds
get closer on that toilet oh my god
there's [ __ ] on there
this is the toilet dude
dude there's [ __ ] on your toilet all
over the toilet i'm talking about
outside of the ball
crap yeah because you're drinking in
dirt
oh my god what do you think of julie
moving to alabama
i don't understand how it's going to
work practically i mean
doesn't he need to be at the show in the
office
i know it's out of the way and it's a
far commute
my main way was my family and so
truly was there any part of you that
thought what's the funniest place i
could move to
and then you came up with alabama sal i
heard you're upset about
mitigation right it's common sense just
mitigate you need to mitigate that means
stop going out wear your masks
stay quarantined stay at home mitigate
mitigate yeah there's your wife she just
walked in yes she's just walking through
can i tell her can i just tell you how
sorry i am for you may you marry this
out that's all thank you i'm
listening
moved to a really nice apartment but
he's surrounded by rats
and he taped it this is the noise he
hears next to his head when he's trying
to sleep rats scratching through the
[Music]
hear walls squeaking yeah he should be
having a
like a what do you call it one of those
dudes that kills all those pests
that's called an exterminator no that's
called a mitigator
robin is jd your exercise teacher now
like he's your guru he motivates you
he's mentoring me for
for like certain life things
why don't you do your push-ups and jd
can tell me what each one is
that trampoline yeah can you imagine
living below this [ __ ] guy
jumping on a trampoline oh my god and
then he's gonna put his head right
through the ceiling
you built the exact power drill that
eddie van halen used it's a makita 6012
it's from the late 80s it was one of the
first
cordless power drills so then you plug
it in at the beginning of the song pound
cake
eddie goes like this
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
look at you my whole weekend was eddie
van halen it was this guitar this drill
i thought you had a girlfriend
who's in gary's house hello hello get
over here
now he has a mask why would you come in
from the outside after you've been with
your college situation
i don't understand what you just did i i
totally agree with you
i'm sorry dad did you wash that hand
i did i sanitized and i will use these
hands to write you a very good eulogy
we conducted a social experiment a zoom
happy hour for the whack pack
tan mom was the last to arrive hey guys
patricia's on where's your video we
don't see you
i know this is terrible i had so much
trouble getting on
is she on zoom i don't see though
i i i can hi hang up or click click
click on your own
image and then when it says stop stop
still not
video click that not only could she not
figure it out at one point
she was on facetime and adam bartow was
on zoom holding the facetime it was so
banana things took a real turn when king
of all blacks tried to explain how he
was on
more of an upper level than everyone
else there i'm insulted even being on
here with these [ __ ]
you're an [ __ ] you are such a deleted
king then called jeff the drunk a loser
oh by the way jeff was like 30 minutes
late to the [ __ ] thing
can we just say hello to mr jeff curl
who's checked in
jeff the trunk hey man another
how does it feel to be a loser on friday
night
look in the mirror and tell me i ain't
no loser [ __ ]
medicated pete we know he can't say
goodbye to anyone on the phone he has
ocd
and his problem is he can't say goodbye
so sour shoes and medicated pete stayed
on after
everybody else had left
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
ronnie is super depressed and you can
understand why dude how much [ __ ]
time have i got [ __ ] left here to
have a good time
i gotta [ __ ] sit here and do nothing
right this is some of your good time
being used up
he was leaving work early to make movie
appearances he'd
leave you sandler i'm here yeah
stephanie i am worried about ronnie what
is your assessment of ronnie's condition
right now
he's cooking he's cleaning i i honestly
i can't complain about that
you know i got to be honest with you
i've never seen you before in your
hospital outfit i gotta say you've never
looked more like his nurse than uh ever
before
the guys are complaining that ronnie is
taking over the zoom happy hour
[ __ ] drinks delivered to his house
[ __ ] you i didn't
i didn't say complain that was someone
else yeah it's always somebody else you
never do anything
i go inside and i'm trying to [ __ ] and
i break out into the sweat and i thought
i was gonna pass out on the toilet i was
dying i stuck my hand in there
like these these three fingers wow
i just shoved it in there and i'm
pulling it was like
it was like [ __ ] cement and then all
of a sudden
this big giant [ __ ] one big brick
came out
and it was like they gave birth wow and
it all
it all just [ __ ] eased up right look
the
that's what it looked like i'm not
kidding you why does he have a rock in
his [ __ ] house
fred why the [ __ ] do i have to tell
anybody who the [ __ ] i'm voting for
playing it simple
why are you so afraid to tell everybody
no why do i have to do
why are you so afraid to tell everybody
why do i have to
tell anyone why maybe i'm not happy with
anybody
who i'm voting for no you don't but it
probably would be a smart idea
why girl you're the king of ball buster
we all we've all busted that's why we
love you
this is not ball busting this is [ __ ]
true [ __ ] coming out
what truth did you learn today seriously
enough no i'm serious enough like do you
think fred hates you now
no i didn't say he hated me but i know
how he feels
he's disappointed in your vote but he
still likes you is that he doesn't know
my [ __ ] vote
ronnie i want you to have a good weekend
i don't want you to get all upset
whoa come on
[Laughter]
john bonham the great drummer possibly
the greatest drummer that ever lived
this is the 40th anniversary of his
death
when the levee breaks that drum rip it's
one of the most sampled drum beats
ever recorded who's a better drummer
than him go ahead joe in new jersey
i think he should call lars he was on
last week i think he's got a true
opinion on this one
lars would say without thinking that
john bonzo bonham was the number one
drummer
of all time no neil pierce how much you
want to bet i'll bet you 100 bucks
joe is on the phone lars who had the
balls to call me up and argue with me
about john bonzo bonham's drums he says
neil peart is better it's a blah blah
blah blah blah
lars is the expert let's find out what
lars thinks
uh it's [ __ ] hard listen i've i've
been asked that question on and off
40 years you mentioned when the levee
breaks i mean that's
classic bottom the drums are big
thunderous ambient he's a little bit
behind on this guy
i like where you're going with your
whole build up i think
we're going to do it yeah
maybe we want to hear your opinion of
neo
the first time i ever met neil it was
1984
our manager cliff signed rush and i had
drum questions about gear
and this and that he goes neil loves to
talk to younger drummers
he goes call neil he wants to hear from
you and it was like
huh i was uh 20 years old
with not a part to prison and uh i
called him and we spoke
30 45 minutes on the phone and we're
geeking out on drums and
the whole thing was like a fairy tale
you can't
play drums and not love neil and
but listen oh no i mean
territory i mean i didn't know i didn't
know laws were getting drum lessons from
neil peart on the phone i mean
jesus christ watching him talk about
neil i'm like he's in love [ __ ] there
goes my hundred dollars
is there a drum roll uh can we have a
drum roll
between neal and between john
no disrespect but i'll have to go with
john bonham
i knew it joe joe you give that hundred
dollars to my charity
certainly you must have a message for
the people go ahead we all
can get through this it's going to be a
long time we don't know when it's going
to end but
if we get each other's back and be kind
and good to each other
uh we'll get through it and uh and
everything
and we'll come out of this stronger look
what you just did
with just a couple of words you healed
america science knows
the answer to this there is an end to it
at some point and we just gotta
you know figure out a way to to get
there when you're in a stressful
experience in life personally or in this
case
globally you must always zoom out you
must zoom out
don't zoom in zoom out so if you look at
history you look at
the world you look at how this has
happened before many times that nature
has its corrections and its movements
and its
uh hostilities
you could even call it that imagine
you're an ant and you built this
incredible ant hill with all these
passageways and things and then some kid
comes and kicks it over
is that what's happening nature is
kicking our anthill yes that's what
happened
all right well let's get back to work
we've been through it before we were
attacked
we lived through the aids epidemic in
1957 there was a flu that killed nearly
a million people there was world war ii
there was the holocaust
there there are people killing other
people on a routine basis
and yet the human spirit uh built into
the human spirit as a resilience
unlike any other mechanism on the planet
and this will pass and we will survive
to the nurses and the doctors and the
first responders
and everybody involved man you my hero
what affects one of us
affects us of all this is the equalizer
i don't give a [ __ ] how much money you
got or what color you got
you going to so we all got to stick
together
i don't get what color you are or what
creed or what economic
status you got i love you and everybody
please stay safe
out there how are you dealing with covet
19.
are you a barn house i have a mask i
also put a mask on my ass for the people
who are driving behind me
because who knows what a cove
toot can do you put a mask on your
[ __ ] and uh in case of uh
of course liquid you know when you put a
face mask on you put it on your ears
well how do you keep it on
it's penis fantastic
each side would it be appropriate to
close out this segment with you giving
america
a message of hope through your butcher
god
i thought the best way to reveal my
decision about continuing on after 44
years or not continuing on
would be to go to marianne from brooklyn
and why maryam from brooklyn i just feel
maryam from brooklyn has been a loyal
fan
she's very concerned about whether i'm
signing or not what i delivered to
marianne's house
these are safe oh my god howard you got
to be kidding me i don't know how to use
this dave
inside that pink safe is the answer
as to whether i'm staying or leaving i'm
going to give you clues so you can
figure out the combination to the safe
oh dear
oh boy if you enter the wrong
combination it will detonate
and you will blow your whole house and
yourself included
well marianne this could be the
interview you know what i was gonna do
there are four digits to open the safe
the first two digits are ronnie's
favorite number 69 right so
put in six 9
69 and now if you get the next two
numbers right
you'll open that up and you'll read to
everyone what my decision is about
staying or leaving
oh my god the second two numbers
are the amount of years robin and i have
been broadcasting together on the air
33 no 39
try it
i did 39. all right i'll open it
it's not opening maybe i have to do it
oh you opened it oh great okay
okay okay wait wait how does it open
help me the hell is going on she won't
be able to open the door
[Music]
[Music]
once you open it read to us whether i'm
staying or leaving
the rating can't open it i can't get it
open
we have four hours oh my god i'm sorry
is she turning the knob can i call my
husband he's very good at it
oh just twist the knob
okay there's an envelope inside holy
[Music]
[ __ ]
my goodness and what does it say mary
and nobody knows
[Music]
that's right marianne i'm staying on the
radio
i've uh signed a five-year deal
with um serious satellite radio i'll
stay for another five years
five years for how long five
five years for how long
[Music]
what does that mean i
thank you mary that's funny wow